can I just say something as well on that  subject I think that in itself sends out  a bad message to what's happening like  with women these days because she is  another woman who doesn't listen to her  man yeah yeah you see when there's  around a red table talking remember he  says something about old I'll give you  my permission and she was like no you  don't give me no permission so this is  the message that a lot of these girls  are getting that you know you can have a  man that's going to go and risk it all  to protect you but you don't have to  listen to him when he says anything you  can do what the hell you want humiliate  him and it's all good you know but it's  not the real world really